what do you uh is the most beautiful
idea in mathematics
another one we can ask is which is the
most beautiful equation in mathematics
well I mean
I may have just broken your brain
because because what your brain is doing
is walking down a long memory lane
of beautiful experiences
well you see in mathematics we have this
idea that we have an idea of a set right
so it could be a collection of things
for instance you know the set of tables
the the set of chairs and so on outside
of microphones
but could be set of numbers
could be a set of ideas it could be a
set of formulas mathematical equations
and then we have the notion of an
ordered set ordered like we said in
which there is order which means that
for every two members of the set we'll
say which one is better than the other
or greater than the other for instance
all numbers are ordered
5 is greater than 3 5 is less than seven
and so on
but not all sets are ordered so the set
of beautiful theorems is not what
beautiful equations is not ordered
so in other words there are many best
equations
and so
Richard Feynman uh
um chose one which I think one of the
best is that if you take e the base of
natural logarithm to the power Pi I so
you have Pi you have e in it the base of
initial logarithm you have Pi I which is
square root of negative one
then the result is negative one
so that's up there for sure in the
pantheon of beautiful formulas you know
that uh every I think pretty much every
mathematician would agree
um I don't know what my favorite one is
I just lingering on that one uh Euler's
identity what makes it beautiful just a
few symbols together right
I mean part of it is actually just
trying to Define what what is beautiful
about mathematics
um that is
uh Laden there in this particular
equation that is somehow revealed when
the human eye looks at it
why is it beautiful do you think
pi
there is an element of surprise in it
how is it possible we always think of Pi
as the ratio between the circumference
of a circle and its diameter
here we are taking some number to the
power Pi not even Pi mind you but by
multiply by square root of negative one
surely this is something completely
incomprehensible and yet the result is
negative one
you see and if you take e to the power 2
pi I you get one actually one
um so I would guess that that's but in
other words the initial
reaction is just that of a surprise I
guess I guess for anyone
who first comes across that these three
folks four folks got together yeah it uh
it reminds me of the
the idea that uh Hitler Stalin Trotsky
and Freud were all in Vienna in some
early at the beginning of the 20th and
business Stein was was classmate of of
Hitler you know this I did not know this
though yeah so there it makes you you
know you can imagine a situation where
they're all sitting at a bar together
at some point not knowing it but they
somehow it all made sense in space time
to be located there and that's what this
feels like some kind of intersection
intersection yes but I would say that
after the initial shock you you look at
the proof of this equation and it
actually does make sense and actually it
is is nothing but the statement that the
circumference of the circle is
and in fact in this case is the
circumference of a semicircle is equal
to Pi to Pi and that's where it comes
from in the end the truth is simple
in the end it was a simple not
necessarily easy but simple